predators that chase down their prey on
the open Savannah are some of the most
athletic creatures on the planet the
cheetah is the fastest land animal and
can run at speeds of up to 60 miles per
hour these extraordinary abilities have
emerged through an evolutionary arms
race where both predator and prey have
evolved to become faster and more
athletic but during a chase it's not
just about strength speed and agility
it's also about strategy so we wanted to
investigate the actual tactics of a hunt
what the Prix is doing to maximize its
chances of evading the predator what the
predator is doing to maximize its
chances of capturing the prey we
selected two pairs of animals the lion
and the zebra and the cheetah and the
Impala and we measured five different
metrics we measured the muscle power we
measured their top speed we measured
their ability to accelerate or turn and
we measured their stride frequency so to
measure these things used wildlife
tracking collars this is a cheetah
collar a zebra collar and a lion collar
the electronics are all very similar on
the top we've got a GPS antenna and
solar panels and this has got all the
movement sensors that we use the GPS the
accelerometers gyroscopes that actually
capture the moon to me on them all these
are fairly robust plastic if we look at
some like the lion color this is four
millimeter polycarbonate effectively
bulletproof glass so when we analyze
these data the Predators were more
athletic than the prey and really every
metric they were faster their muscles
were more powerful they could accelerate
and decelerate more quickly this makes
sense the predator has to be more
athletic the prey is defining the terms
of the hunt
it is always one stride ahead and the
predator is always playing catch-up and
reacting to what the prey has just
decided to do so it's not surprising we
see greater athleticism in predators so
we have hunting data for the predator
and for the prey but we don't have it
for the same hunt so we get around this
by using a computer simulation where we
can vary the conditions and explore what
the outcome is so here is a model we've
got in red the pre running away from the
predator and then blue from the predator
approaching the prey in the next two
strides the predator is going to reach
the prey so in the first right the prey
makes a decision to move it can turn
left or right or speed up or slow down
so it can move anywhere in the red
ellipse the predator doesn't know what
the prey is going to do so it carries on
at the same speed straight ahead in the
second stride the prey can continue
making a second maneuvering decision the
predator has sensed what the tree is
doing and will then react to that by
attempting to capture the prey the
larger the area of the red ellipse
covered by the Predators blue ellipse
the greater chance the predator has of
capturing the prey so you might think
the pre strategy should be to run as
quickly as possible away from the
predator that is absolutely not the case
because the predator is faster and is
catching the prey out and actually for
the prey it wants to be moving slowly
because that gives it a much greater
range of options to outmaneuver the
predator it can turn it can speed up it
can slow down and it's all about
unpredictability for the predator it
wasn't supposed to be moving as quickly
as possible and it doesn't want to be
moving much faster than the prey if the
predator is moving very quickly it makes
it much harder for it to turn sharply
and that limits its ability to right
maneuver the play you've looked at the
athlete the predator and the prey what
we see is very informative in terms of
how athletic these species need to be to
survive what the evolutionary arms race
actually looks like to biomechanical and
locomotor prospective
you
[Music]